du verre et du rouge le choix du décor
pour cette réunion avec les partenaires
sociaux n'a pas été choisi au hasard la
réforme présentée ce matin introduit tel
un bison Futé de l'emploi des périodes
vertes dès que le taux de chômage est
inférieur à 9 % tant que le taux de
chômage reste sous les 9 % la situation
du marché du travail est considéré
favorable la durée d'indemnisation sera
alors diminuée de 25% par exemple elle
passera de 24 à 18 mois en revanche si
le repasse au-dessus de 9%, les règles
actuelles s'appliquent avec les
difficultés de recrutement que nous
rencontrons le marché du travail dans un
contexte favorable qui justifie le
modulation à la baisse de la durée
maximum d'indemnisation ce n'est pas une
réforme comme il le dit
incitative pour faire face aux offres
non pourvues cette réforme et encore une
fois pour but à un but purement
économique c'est les seniors qui vont
payer le plus cher sur cette réforme
quelqu'un qui a été licencié par exemple
de plus de 55 ans actuellement le droit
à
36 mois d'allocations chômage on va se
retrouver avec 27 donc 9 mois de mois ça
accélère la fin de droit on a averti
qu'il fallait pas baisser les la durée
de la durée de la durée d'indemnisation
pour ces salariés là parce que en fait
quand vous avez plus de 55 ans plus
personne ne vous embauche et donc vous
avez forcément vous vous transformez en
chômeur de longue durée on a un marché
de l'emploi qui n'a jamais connu autant
de dynamique avec beaucoup de beaucoup
de propositions et de postes et un
dispositif de cette nature et nous
pensons
un dispositif qui permet en tout cas
d'aller dans le bon sens et en tout cas
vers le retour au travail je ne veux
plus que l'on parle de la France moche
la phrase est signée ce matin Caroline
cailleux la ministre délégué au
collectivités territoriales pilote le
programme Action cœur de ville le
deuxième volet prévoit 5 milliards
d'euros pour financer des projets
d'embellissement de ville moyenne il
faudra que ça suffise il faudra que on
complète si nécessaire pour protéger
toutes les entreprises face à
l'augmentation des prix de l'électricité
ici le faute d'électricité ou les prix
du gaz et je veux que les choses soient
bien entendu nous ne laisserons tomber
aucune entreprise nous sommes quittés
vendredi matin à 10h30 et la grande
majorité des migrants qui avaient
remarquer de l'océan Viking était encore
dans le centre de vacances de la
presqu'île de Giens ce matin ils sont
moins de 10 dans cette zone d'attente
pour des raisons légales juridiques ou
administratives dont je vous passe les
détails ces migrants sont dans la nature
ce matin une vaste enquête des autorités
italiennes clôturée en mars 2021 accuse
des responsables de 3 ONG d'avoir
facilité le trafic de migrants
l'association Save the Children via le
bateau VOST etia Médecins Sans
Frontières via le vote prudence et
Hughes via le yuana et la guerre
[Musique]
positives cette enquête s'appuie sur des
saisies à bord des bateaux des écoutes
téléphoniques mais aussi sur le
témoignage d'un policier infiltré parmi
les équipes de sauvetage au total 21
suspects sont visés arrêtez cette folie
l'appel lancé par le chef de
internationale de l'énergie atomique des
experts doivent se rendre aujourd'hui en
Ukraine à zaporigia pour évaluer les
dégâts après les bombardements de ce
week-end près de la plus grande centrale
nucléaire d'Europe la Russie et
l'Ukraine s'accuse mutuellement aucun
accident nucléaire n'a été détecté le
niveau de radiation reste conforme à la
norme ce matin mais le danger d'une
catastrophe est plus que jamais à
l'ordre du jour depuis plus de 10 jours
un troupeau de moutons tourne dans le
sens des aiguilles d'une montre sans
aucune raison le cercle s'est formé dans
l'enclos numéro 13 d'une ferme du nord
de la Chine mais la raison serait
scientifique peut être une contamination
à la listeria qui provoque chez l'animal
des troubles neurologiques et voici la
Lune comme vous ne l'avez jamais vu on
va découvrir ici sa face cachée grâce à
la mission Artémis cinq jours après son
lancement la capsule Orion se trouve à
seulement 123 km de notre satellite